now let's get into that story from
timcast.com
majority of americans no longer believe
that biden is competent do you know you
know if it wasn't on timcast.com i'd
almost assume this article was fake news
you know why
it implies that at some point people did
believe joe biden was competent right
so now they don't this is the one thing
well you know what it is is that people
live in the media they so when the media
is saying biden's great everyone's like
okay and now that he's botching
afghanistan and the media is criticizing
him now the people who don't pay
attention are all of a sudden shocked to
realize
but he's doing bad and isn't it funny
how these polls track with the
mainstream media narrative they say
according to a new poll from cbs 51
believe that biden is not a competent
commander-in-chief well 49 believe that
he is i'd like to meet at least one of
these 49 percent
who are these people that after
everything we've seen
the pollsters also found that 52 percent
of likely voters do not feel the
president has been focused
i just i just
who who's this 48 percent that has heard
the man speak and heard the word true
nanasha pressure and decided that was
focused i know those people are they're
my family they're my friends there's
tons of people yeah i know i mean that's
true and i don't think you could
throttle them into reality i really
don't
yeah you know and that's really sad and
it's unfortunate for me because it's
cost me friendships it's cost me a lot
but i those 49 of people do exist and i
don't think that they're necessarily
willing to wake up to what's actually
happening
yeah it's it's it's
safe
yeah we've got these baby chicks okay
we've had we had we had i think 14 eggs
and we're not good at what we're doing
so most of them didn't make it but three
of them did and they're actually pretty
spunky and strong
and they are scared to leave their
little brooder box it's safe it's warm
now one of them though is always like
peeking out
you know and it wants there's one that
that one that's brave and that's that's
what this reminds me of
the two of the three they're like scared
and they're just like i don't want to
leave it's warm and safe don't make me
go i don't want to go in the real world
and i i look at them and i'm like they
would have voted for joe biden
it's it's just easy
you know it's you don't got to think
it's like you know we hear from these
youtubers like you don't even get a
thing you just go to the website and
it's all done for you here's where it
gets here here's where uh well this is
interesting the cbs poll was conducted
as afghanistan fell to the taliban and
53 disagreed with the way that the
troops were withdrawn 70 said the
removal of troops could have been
handled better along with 55 percent who
said some troops could have stayed
according to breitbart news now the sad
part is we'll go to the bottom there's a
couple things here rasmussen found that
55 of voters believe harris is not
qualified to assume the duties of the
presidency including 47 percent who said
she is not qualified at all wow
jeez
that's harsh
what 43 percent of likely voters
believed she is ready to be the
president way down from 49 back in april
a couple interesting things
civics shows
joe biden's job approval by state in
almost every single state joe biden is
underwater with disapproval it is
california connecticut new jersey new
york hawaii oregon illinois rhode island
maryland massachusetts vermont and
washington that have a positive view of
joe biden
yeah
basically blue states of course count on
it the craziest thing about all this i
suppose is
it's it's independent voters are driving
all of this republicans hate biden and
democrats love biden and that's not
changing but independent voters are
are are
shifting away 57 percent disapprove of
joe biden
so i don't know what this means i mean
maybe we'll get a 25th amendment i'm
really shaken with his uh his behavior
in the last couple weeks it's nice to
see the polls like this catching up i
don't know did you catch so many people
were pulled or if it was like a
nationwide poll
uh well civics is 91 514 responses but
that's over a couple years um i don't
know i can pull up the cbs one though i
when this afghanistan thing went down i
don't know if it was intentional and
they're like you're gonna make us pull
out fine we'll show you what a pull out
looks like here suck it or if it was
just biden was so is such a poor
military commander he's the
commander-in-chief of the u.s armed
forces he's such a poor military
commander that he just didn't understand
tactics like you leave air support in
while you move people out on the ground
it could have been a three-month process
moving people out he had he had he had
all year and they rushed he knew so it's
2142 adults with a margin of error
margin of error of plus 2.3 percent
2 000 that's a that's a big sample right
i got like a pang of fear thinking what
if this stupid chinese boogie man the
ccp but like if there was some sort of
like
coordinated invasion right now with
biden at the helm if he really doesn't
isn't a good commander and then we have
to fight a war
we lose because the commander
misappropriates the first days are the
most
you know
vulnerable moments in a war you know you
know what i think this
people that were saying that
afghanistan has revealed the emperor has
no clothes
and you know what's crazy to me is this
realization because i've actually even
though i know joe biden's kind of like
you know not all with it i still felt
like you know people say like oh who's
biden's handler who's really pulling the
strings oh it's going to be kamala and
you see afghanistan it's like dude
they're they're legit following biden
and so when biden mutters stutters and
stammers and falls asleep they just sit
there
like i genuinely thought there were
people like picking up the slack for
biden
after all this
i it's like people were mia like where
was kamala she wasn't speaking now
you've got this video where she's
walking out and the reporter's like i
want to ask you about you know the
people and she's like
and people are like why is she laughing
she laughs at really weird times she's a
weird person yeah yeah i don't know man
i think that biden did have people
picking up the slack for him and i'm
afraid that the people who were doing
that for joe were people like mark milly
people who were focused on things like
white rage no instead of what it would
have been like to pull out properly i
think mark milley is is an example of
the fact that biden's just sleeping in
his they probably walk in the oval
office he's like
and then mark millie's like yes
you know that no one's going to fire me
now because biden's asleep he can't do
it unless he wakes up yeah maybe
yeah how do we have these people woke
generals chaos it's the end of the
american empire i forget which
commentator i listen to mention this but
you just see joe biden you see him
walking away from these press
conferences you see him walking up to
the podium this is not the face of a
healthy democracy it just i mean it it's
and it's painful to watch it really is
and i i feel those pains that you're
talking about when i see him speak and
i mean and it's at a certain point it
just it it it's not even funny you know
i mean like some people still just kind
of want to pile on to him and make fun
of him and it's not funny it it feels
like
he is uh
genuinely struggling to put together a
sentence to put together a perspective
and to lead the nation and how is it
only now i guess i made the point right
people were following the media
but only now
these independent voters are like hmm
maybe this you know 79 78 year old he's
gonna be 79 soon 78 year old guy who
can't talk well
there's something wrong with him that's
that's what i was going to ask you what
do you think it was it was the straw
that broke the camel's back essentially
was it afghanistan or was it just like
this was the final thing the latest
thing that's really just made people
kind of see what's happening this is
what's scary about it is that
it's whatever cnn tells them yeah you
know and and cnn's like biden's great
and they're like okay and now
afghanistan like cnn wants war
war is good for the for the bottom line
for all these media companies
now
they're like oh he really messed this
one up and now regular people are like
cnn said he messed it up so he did
there you go
the funny thing is he hasn't lost in the
civics poll shows biden hasn't lost a
single percentage point from democrats
since the fall of kabul till today
like i just
it's it's it's it's a cult i wish i
could say it surprised me honestly but
it doesn't and it is a cult yeah yeah i
see that
here's the thing about trump trump was
giving a speech and he told everyone to
go get the vaccine and they booed him
yeah and i'm i'm laughing like oh geez
but that doesn't that prove it's not a
cult
even trump's most dire supporters are
like no trump you're wrong that's that's
that to me that's kind of that says a
lot
and i think that shows that uh trump is
the avatar for that working-class anger
these people are not blindly following
trump a lot of them are yeah a lot of
them are a lot of but but to boo him
when he said that there's there's they
they're raised
yeah they they they they said no trump
is not the nlpl but biden people just
say go biden
sam harris tweeted something you got you
guys know samuel
yeah and he was like
unlike you know the trump supporters
that blindly just defend trump you know
i'm gonna criticize joe biden it's like
oh you're so brave you and cnn
criticizing joe biden wow for once
that's really unfortunate about sam
harris i really think that he's one of
the public intellectuals who got broken
in some sense during the lockdown i
think i think something like
triggered in his brain and he hasn't
recovered in some sense because used to
i would be able to listen to him and i
would hear coherent thoughts even when i
disagreed but lately he's just been on
some sort of bandwagon that doesn't even
follow up with a lot of the stuff he
used to claim
what happened to people i know i know
yeah i got a story about that actually
and this is
it really hit home with me because
like my best friend 15 years we've we've
been best friends for a really long time
and i sent him a text message i was like
do you see the key to nyc situations
yeah and well he's a chicago guy you
know blue pulled all the way lori
lightfoot supporter you know still still
still
um and uh
he
so i
i told about the key to nyc program i
was like you saw this right he's like
yeah yeah it's great oh sorry sorry
that's what he said he said this is this
is effing great and i was just like this
is fascism he said i don't care if it is
i love it this is exactly what needs to
happen these mandates need to be in
place and people need to follow in line
or not and i said i didn't realize that
you were a fascist i hadn't i hadn't
realized you became radicalized yeah and
he said chris we're gonna have to
disagree on this
and i said no no we're not disagreeing
you're disagreeing with the definition
of fascism yeah and he goes
do you want to still be friends
or are you going to let this go it's a
simple question
i got its answer i mean but but it's not
just
i don't know i haven't heard from him
since and i didn't message him back
actually i did message him i said that
sounds exactly like something a fascist
would say
but but but it's it these kind of
derangement fits happen on personal
levels and they also happen in these
kind of national displays like on
twitter and i see more and more of that
and it's really disturbing to me i love
this reference i use the galaxy quest
one you guys have seen galaxy quest yeah
oh yeah tim allen yeah tony shalhoub's
character is just like laughing they're
they're they're tv actors on a spaceship
they're gonna die and he's just like i
guess we're gonna die whatever he's
laughing that's kind of how i feel about
everything you know not to like downplay
it but people often say like how did you
know nazi germany get to the point to to
violate godwin's law outright how did
nazi germany get to that point it's like
you're sitting here right now like new
york is mandating
identification and and uh uh proof of
vaccination to enter a restaurant it's
like i get it if you want to if you're
concerned about your health and there's
a medication it's fda approved
congratulations you can go to doctor you
can figure out for yourself but for the
city to be like fire all of your
disabled employees like uh
we've we've certainly crossed the line
here yeah and what's funny is i taught
you you saw you mentioned about your
friend they're cheering for it yeah
they're they're they love it mm-hmm that
crazy they feel like their tribe is
winning
right i mean isn't is there some sort of
like very basic tribal element to this
yeah
yeah man
but what but but there's no i guess
these people don't understand that
they're not
they're not in the the actual tribe of
elitism
those that run the systems and are
locking everything down will throw them
into the gutter at a moment's notice but
so they're just standing there gloating
saying ha ha i'm in the winning team and
i'm like i don't care who's leave me
alone
you can go like i feel like i'm watching
a hockey game and they're like just
playing really aggressive and i'm not
playing the game and i'm like just get
away from me and they're trying to throw
me into the rink to play and i'm like no
they just and and now they're throwing
stuff at the stands and i'm like why are
you throwing stuff at me like i got
nothing to do with your game would you
fight to protect people that hated you
that's a good question
i guess there's a lot of nuance in that
question though i don't know how to
answer it like if you're destined to be
a villain even if you protect the people
if there was like some if there was like
an antifa guy and he was like yelling
and cussing at me and then like
you know he was like walking away and a
car was speeding at him full speed i'd
probably try and save him yeah you know
this the g.i joe in you
well it's just like the dude you're
allowed to hate me man you know like if
the guy's not being violent or if he was
violent towards me i'd probably run away
i'd probably be like nah i'm not going
to get anywhere near this guy
it's not a good idea but if there was
like someone who was like i hate you
you're dumb and then i saw a car coming
i'd be like look out and i try and save
them so there's a difference between
being violent towards you and hating you
i suppose that's where there's some
nuance there yeah if they're like
throwing rocks at me i just be like no
i'm not going anywhere near that guy you
know what about you ian uh based on your
question yeah i would
be thankless
also i wonder like if you're preserving
like low intelligence humans that just
eat and reproduce and eat and reproduce
and then starve out the system if you're
actually doing a disservice to the
species
i don't know it's weird dangerous
questions right it's very ethical and
like um what's the genetic what's that
gen um
yeah eugenic it's very eugenic way to
look at like should they live or should
they die but i mean that's basically
what governments do and you know i'll
tell you this for a fact that these
these uh powerful interests have asked
themselves these questions
no no no doubt about it because uh when
we had alex jones here
i asked him that question on the show
what if
the the all of this stuff about the end
you know the end and overpopulation is
true
and we as humans are just yeast in a
bottle consuming all the resources and
farting ourselves to death and
he said you know outside he's like i ask
myself that question all the time but
how do you answer it it's it's it's a
legitimate question the problem is
you know i can't remember exactly what
he said but he was like you know you got
to defend freedom and liberty we
no individual person is going to be
smart enough to steer the ship properly
and we can rely on human nature which
has always found solutions through
ingenuity and invention or we can just
hand it off some desperate authoritarian
who we know through history has always
oppressed murdered and punished it's
tough man it you know because we we're
at what like eight billion people
there's like insect populations
declining there's dead zones in the
ocean
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you